how old are you I'm 28. I think 28's a
tricky number because people get
confused because your post College era
30s look at you in the face yeah that's
that's my biggest problem I've been
having lately and that's I've been
watching a lot of you and all kinds of
other stuff and it's helped me kind of
come out and realize you know my time is
is when I ever find it I got my own
clock bro honestly no joke I feel like
you're closer to 2.8 years old than the
way you think about 28 like you've got
16 years of execution in front of you
because I'm telling you that looking at
30 like wait a minute 30s here shouldn't
I quote unquote have my life together
and then at 28 you got five to fifty
percent of your friends that you went to
high school or college with that are
like you know getting married getting
somewhere in their life don't let
anybody else's clock you know dictate
your game